en 1972
l'excès de vitesse est à l'origine du
quart des accidents engageant la
responsabilité des conducteurs et près
de la moitié des accidents corporels
sont provoquées également par une
vitesse excessive
malgré cela les provençaux est
accueillie de façon mitigée la
limitation à 100 km heure prévue pour le
1er juillet prochain
je trouve que c'est trop jeune à mon
avis pour la voiture que j'ai
personnellement et 110 était déjà un peu
jeune j'en mettrais s'en va ce serait
bien vous pensez que cela pourrait quand
même limiter les risques d'accidents
si les gens sont honnêtes
cette irritation même 220 oui mais
on voit beaucoup de fous sur la route
secret l'accident je suis me conformerai
de toute façon
enfin
dans la mesure où sur les autoroutes la
limitation en ehpad n'est pas limité
puisqu'il en était question je trouve
que
c'est très bien je ne vous gênera pas
personnellement non je pense que tout le
monde devrait de mon avis
personnellement vous ne dépassez jamais
les 100 km de là je ne dépasse jamais
non je jeu des passes et surtout sur la
sur l'autoroute mais moi je trouve que
c'est chez tout un règlement vraiment
très bien mais est-ce que vous n'allez
pas être frustré de rouler à 100 leur
sur la plupart du réseau
je pense je pense parce que je trouve
que la vitesse
c'est pas d'aller vite qui est vraiment
imprudent choix je suis contre la
limitation de vitesse parce que ne
suffit pas de limiter la vitesse pour
yves des accidents il suffirait
simplement que les gens respectent le
code de la route
à partir de ce moment là on réduirait
les accidents de d'au moins 80%
pour les conducteurs chevronnés et le
fait de rouler à plus de 100 kilomètres
heure n'apparaît pas comme une cause
majeure d'accident il suffit selon eux
d'être capable de contrôler son véhicule
c'est l'avis de robert manzo un ancien
pilote de course champion de france de
formule 1 en 1950 devant les 14
accidents fréquents les dimanches et les
jours de fête des mesures étaient
nécessaires mais limité la vitesse par
le bas à mon avis est une erreur parce
que trop de voitures marchent lentement
créé des bouchons d énervement
je suis à nantes les automobilistes de
provence et ceux du sud est ne sont pas
très satisfaits de la limitation de
vitesse à 100 kilomètres à l'heure sur
l'ensemble du réseau comme l'a décidé ce
pierre messmer hier soir par exemple
pour une raison très simple les atomes
big love ont toujours été contre une
habitation généralisée et pour une
modèle pour une modulation des
limitations de vitesse c'est à dire
l'adaptation de la limitation ou
circonstance que ce soit le véhicule que
ce soit le conducteur que ce soit la
route et par conditions les conditions
du trafic
parce que au fond la règle de base c'est
l'arrivée du bon sens c'est-à-dire
adapter son véhicule et être maître de
lui c'est la règle numéro 1 du code de
la route d'ailleurs
donc il faut que les conducteurs
prennent conscience de sa responsabilité
au volant et adapte sa vitesse aux
circonstances
les automobile clubs demandent donc le
contrôle régulier et obligatoire des
véhicules et une meilleure formation des
conducteurs
peut être verrons nous un jour un permis
de conduire accessibles en un deux ou
trois degrés comme c'est le cas pour les
brevets de pilote
[Musique]